potevo cambiare maglia prima di fare il
gameplay perché se no sembra che indosso
sempre stesse maglie durante i video
però non c'ho voglia di farlo del puzzo
ok puzzo della tutti ragazzi è bene che
sono video sono fallite o ci siamo sul
naso brutto simulator new game
di sicuro tutti i progressi della storia
verranno persi perché nella mia vita
passata io avevo giocato sta roba non
quindi magari potevano esserci dentro
jesi ma che cazzo perché se ci sono
installato adesso gioco instagram ho
trovato questa chiave di un libro di mia
nonna e sono sicuro che che proviene
dall'isola in quarantena dove il mio
nonno lavorava adesso spiegami perchè
cazzuto nonno lavorava in un'isola in
quarantena
vabbè gravi pazzo però sempre il sognato
di trovarla e quindi andrò domani chi è
che viene ma [ __ ] alla madonna che
grafica sembra proprio aver a questa e
che cos'è sta roba una zattera per prima
cosa che mi viene da pensare che non è
una torcia non vedasi o la torcia ma non
vedo un cazzo ugualmente quindi
fantastico ma come cazzo è uscita questa
porta come colorista una porta qua sono
partito piero li isola ancora antenna a
perché tu non hai ancora visto casa mia
a fondo maggio fagioli zio permesso
rimessa alla bella blake
beh la sua zona
[Musica]
ho finalmente una stanza più allegra e
ciò delle bare nell'altra porta la
bestia
però devi stare casa c'erano lucchetto
che basta avete passato invece un
lucchetto non la puoi aprire va bene
bastava quello permesso guarda siete la
cosa più simpatica da quando è iniziato
il gioco per adesso and dance borg che
un tipo di via
fatta quei teschi però è un tipo di
birra
bella questa chiave credo che debba
uscire di quattro mesi futuro ma dove
cazzo uscita questa scala qua e là
compaiono robe che non c'erano accordi
bello questo ospedale piuttosto muoio
che farmi curare qua guardan
questa era la chiave dello spero trovato
la chiave l'ospedale ma non ci aveva la
serratura st porta quindi dovevo
inserita la chiave nel culo ma ben
vengano le serrature sue torte la chiave
due tassi sognata che sbatte le porte
che chiude a orlando si può sapere che
che sposta bottiglie da quando è
iniziato il gioco
senti zecchino d'oro 2.0 e smettila di
sbattere latina i miei fastidio ma in
questo gioco c'è qualcosa oltre alle
tazzine che si muovono tra porteghetto
salve city posso vedere zio
sì però non sia preso parte stai lì
gioca con la playstation
mai però non so voi ma ragazzi la cosa
più horror che ho visto fino adesso sono
i 13 euro e che che ho speso per
acquistarlo però io dei bambini chiusi
queste porte non è sbatto le balle non
so se avrei capito mondo nelle porte
fastidio hanno messo anno
se non piangere che arrivò arriva lo zio
fa vi arrivano jet salde senta l'eta
deve maggiore un po di più che sta
scomparendo e la cosa che mi dicono a me
di solito quando vado in giro reti e
ecco niente mangiato da poco
potete smetterla di più delle porte che
fastidio si sta roba
wow come una cosa che mi interessava
trovare in questo momento la scatola che
contiene la maschera che lei ha
indossato e vuota colmo invio cuore
queste sono le parole che dicono di fran
donati andiamo avanti grazie papi ma
perché spendi 13 euro per queste merde
non lo so
a un pezzo di maschera di trovare i
pezzi della maschera che so io la faccio
oggi grazie caro mario caro mario grazie
mario grazie
ecco qua al resto della maschera
inculati ma no dai basta che palle
loretta vuoi prendere per il culo madre
[ __ ] gesù smette dall'itar tass armi
trequarti di pube e becca di st mascara
iota dovrei spaventarmi
13 euro
faccio una cassetta per per ogni euro
che bel nome anna baker 13 euro di
mortacci di tua sorella
no no no no no no no vi ammazzo ti
ammazzo ti faccio male mi faccio ma
fatemi entrare qua non voglio sapere chi
è che si sta muovendo la smettete di
prendermi per il culo a matri che doveva
farmi in salto ma secondo me le mani non
si sono mica smacchia vedute anzi ti
ringraziano un po di pomate via sesto
rumore bruttissimo tutta la tua madre
brutta quanto non me l'aspettavo
prendono era un jump schermano
l'aspettavo ma la zia ma va a cagare
andata bello sto tombino per me è più
pulito il tombino che il posto stesso si
piacere sono fa vj
trovare fatto affari
cosa mi copre la pista c'è un qualcosa
di non identificato in questo posto
ragazzi e potrebbe essere un problema
per i calmi l'ho visto qui a destra però
ammettere che i jobs che cito non
succede niente ma i jap schermi fa
cagare male cos'era a caso ho avuto un
tic non sono pienamente sicuro che qua
sia la strada giusta però proviamoci lo
stesso ryan un altro cancello ma è
chiuso pure sono dalla parte sbagliata
mi sa
lo zio dove c'è una porta qui che non so
se lui deve effettivamente aperta perché
non so come fare per le porte però è lo
dica roba dove posso andare adesso
evidentemente riesce ad aprire le porte
lo zio si chiude bene
nove sono curioso di vedere con la apre
adesso prova a salire le scale destra di
culo come col quale fisica e bolelli
sarei a pescare deficiente drag e mi
stavi fottendo è testa di culo
[ __ ] ok è questa una mazzata è poi
così brutto vecchio
pensavo peggio ragazzi monte volte
quando mi sveglio sono peggio io gesù
santo benedetto che cosa per aggiungere
una bassa ma per 13 euro questa roba che
se li spende da kiko sono più bello di
bollo money pensate che io ho iniziato a
fare video così come i giochi del genere
non aggiungiamo altro
va bè ragazzi come l'episodio spero che
il video vi sia piaciuto non in gioco il
video perché sono due cose diverse
grazie a dio
ricordatevi sempre che sei una ragazza
di friends on a regalatele una maschera
volevo provare a fare il poeta ma non mi
è venuto niente vedo ragazzi fa vedi se
vi piace anche ai socio anche come in
totale scrizione così rischiate ci
vediamo il prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]